[Musique]
reconnaissable à sa coupe de cheveux
extravagantes pour une fois ce n'est pas
la poule 2 ou dans qui est mise à
l'honneur mais ses cousines la
faverolles pécoul de plus de deux
siècles
[Musique]
c'est une poule t4 à nantes il ya aussi
bien des qualités compte que quelques
des qualités de chair elle et elle est
vraiment très délicat les faverolles de
l'éleveur eric sanson sont arrivés il ya
six mois
elles ont gambadé dans ces grands prix
au milieu des vaches et ont investi ce
poulailler de confort avec portes
automatiques réglé en fonction du lever
et coucher du soleil
à la fin de leur vie on l'est on les
ramène un bon mois dans un box et elles
vont faire un petit peu plus le graal
vont faire elles vont attendre un petit
peu plus la viande de leurs demeures
royales d'auffargis aux cuisines du
trianon palace de versailles
elles ont pas d'hématome ccd des
produits qui sont très bien préparées
elles ont pas été agressé dans les eaux
sont bien nourris
elles ont eu l'honneur d'être la race
choisie par le chef cuisinier des lieux
frédéric largement pour son menu goût de
france le 21 mars dernier
c'est la fête de la gastronomie
française dans le monde entier donc on a
un thème tous les ans le thème cette
annonce et produits de proximité est là
justement on a dans les yvelines se
produit à l'exceptionnelle on va pouvoir
mettre en valeur justement pour le même
goût de goutrens pour sa volaille
faverolles aux herbes de la ferme de la
petite org asperges vertes et morilles
le chef cuisinier conserve chaque partie
de la foule
on utilise le suprême vraiment donc
farce il excuse qui se font en
dodelinant récupère le foie et les
coeurs pour les rôtir les mettre en
bâtonnets pourquoi les enrouler dans le
dans les cuisses et bien sûr ma tout ce
qui reste comme carcassonne les os tout
ça on utilise pour confronter
confectionner le jus un pressage
minutieux pour une poule savoureuse qui
mérite qu'on la prenne avec des
pincettes
[Musique]